pense pas que je pense pas que le
chiffre soit très important peut-être
qu'il ya une certaine dose qui serait
ennuyeux pour lui se traite pas être élu
au premier tour quand le plus qu'on
attend
enfin je pense qu'il sera élu au premier
tour mais s'il l'était pas ce serait
quand même un signe un petit peu de
difficulté et après après tout commence
par quelque sorte
moi je suis de ceux qui croient que même
avec une participation faible
le fait de devenir président du parti
des républicains et même nous un parti
dans un assez triste état va lui donner
une légitimité nouvelle une popularité
qui va augmenter
un rôle reconnu deux chefs de
l'opposition et que en plus la
multiplication des digues armand pour
février à terme de chef de l'opposition
parce qu'il ya mélenchon non cotée qui
prétend ceux-là c'est justement la voit
la différence d'autres j'adore les
interruptions
oui je pense que les égarements de
mélenchon je cherchais un terme qui sera
susceptible de provoquer un déchaînement
inutile
pas de la part des réseaux sociaux font
qu' il ya un besoin d'une place il ya un
besoin d'opposition il ya un besoin de
quelqu'un pour l'incarner qu assez vite
marine le pen en difficulté mélenchon
erratique
il peut occuper cette place